I'm curious Jasmine what is it that you
bring to the table when it comes to a
relationship with a man I knew this
question was coming I I bring to the
relationship yeah table to the table
Yeah because I've heard a lot of you
know demands and holes and love and
Romance I'm just curious like what is it
that you bring okay are we going to talk
about materialism or are we going to
talk about some like deep like um you
know emotional what are the what are the
redeeming qualities that exist within
you that men desire that would want to
invite you into their life and take you
on as a a girlfriend a wife or even
adopt your twin
daughters um that's like going really
far that's like kind of my like red flag
because like what are the qualities that
you bring to the table is what I'm
asking why would a guy be with you why
would I okay first of all I'm a I'm a
very uh dedicated mother like I I'm
really um involved with everything that
I do with my daughters how does that how
does that benefit me as a man you're 42
you can't have any more kids you've
already got kids why is that a benefit
to me well I'm who said that I'm going
to give you
kids that's the point that I'm making
kids I'm not going enter in a
relationship to have a baby maybe I just
want a companion I know but you're
talking about being a great mother how
is that a benefit to me as a man okay
first of all I don't like there's no
benefit to me as a man like do you
understand that yes I understand that
but that's kind of like you speaking
from your own point of view are we
talking about you or
men no I'm ask no I'm asking you what is
it that you bring to the table when it
comes to a relationship the first thing
that you went to is I'm a wonderful
mother yeah those kids aren't mine
you're not going to bring me any new
kids there's no benefit to that story
matters a lot because you have even the
brought the example at the very
beginning of the show which I paid
attention you said a lot of the women
bring men home and you know introducing
their kids with a man that's something I
will never do until I get married to
somebody else I'm very very clear on
that okay so you are not going to see my
child until I really for sure know that
you are seriously in no but I'm asking
what you bring to the table Jasmine I
bring um uh I mean nuring compassionate
you're um not a are you going to provide
you mean I mean I I no longer want to
provide but I will provide because I can
provide
obviously her her being yes I mean I I'm
I'm a very first of all okay I'm a hard
worker I am a exactly what she runs her
whole household by herself can fully run
the house myself yes I'm a great cook I
am a okay the cooking skill is useful
I'm traditional I'm very traditional in
more traditional than most woman out
there in America because I grow up in
Middle East so I kind of understand the
role of how to actually be traditional
because that comes natural to me okay so
that's rare I think right now but you're
not a traditional woman if you're a boss
girl running businesses and you're an
alpha female that's not traditional why
there's a lot of women out there in New
York City if you go on Wall Street you
will see 60 70% do you think that that's
what guys want well well I see a lot of
men wanting the same type of woman and
at the same time doing the double
standards on them so there is a
systematic error I think okay so let me
ask you this question you know like it's
a bit of a followup to it so should
women challenge men in a
relationship what regard what way you
know challenge him you know offer a
challenge in the relationship cheating
sorry about the cheating like no no just
just challenge him in general like you
know create a challenge in the
relationship like not be easy not be
agreeable like be a challenge no the
only kind of challenge should be to make
them better push them to do more to do
better otherwise i' no that's good what
do you think Jasmine do you think that
women should be a challenge in a
long-term
relationship um if you were to ask this
question to me when I was in my 20s I
would like yeah let's challenge that
right now I pick my fights with
everybody even a man or women so I I'm
at a point in my life where I like to
have the ease in the relationship where
I want to be you know understood and at
the same time I want to do my best to
understand the other person and curious
from Anita's perspective what do you
think's going on there do you think that
she's you know I'm sorry from your
perspective do you think that she's uh
like she's obviously saying single right
now right and she's got a very strong
personality how does that sort of jive
with your practice and your work you
know so I am the antithesis of
traditional I was married I stayed at
home I was a stay-at-home wife and
mother for 12 years I helped my then
husband build a
multi-million million dooll business I
took care of our children I took care of
our home I sent them out of the house
with a hot breakfast I welcomed him into
the house with a hot dinner he came home
to a clean home well-mannered children
whatever his need was I provided and
supported and met it okay sexually and
sensually as well so that is traditional
I do not work outside of the home I do
not try to juggle all of these things
including my husband and my children
that doesn't farewell something's going
to fall one of those balls are going to
fall out of the air that's what modern
women don't understand they think they
can have it all but you can't you cannot
have it all Alp female stuff oh no no
no no no no no no I am I am a feminine
woman and I have power by being feminine
so I don't need to label myself as Alpha
my power is in my
femininity so we go back to the argument
of alpha again you just said you
dismissed the definition of alpha but
you Paradox yourself and defining Alpha
again no I was asking Anita from her
perspective from her PR practice what
she saw in the conversation that we were
having you've got a very very strong
personality I'm just wondering how that
works out for you when you're dating
right but it doesn't sound like that you
are because you're only separated for a
year you haven't really been dating yeah
okay well do you think that it's going
to benefit
you being an alha yeah being being
strong
I want to hear being what being strong
willed like that um I mean I really am
happy about myself I'm like happy who I
am so you don't want a man in your life
I did not say that that's generalization
I'm not ready for it yet okay what do
you think guys want that you're looking
for me yeah what do you think guys want
what I mean I mean in where in on online
of course
like a relationship like what do you
think guys are looking for honestly it's
so hard to understand what the guys are
looking for at the same time I would say
what the women are looking for because
everybody is basing on their
expectations based on no I just want to
get my understanding like what is it
that guys are looking for like what do
you need to feed a man to keep him
around um for me
it's
compassion and and wisdom for me those
two things are very like passion and
wisdom rank very low on the list for men
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out